good afternoon everyone today we're
gonna be looking at scp-500 object class
safe special containment procedures the
CP 500 must be stored in a cool and dry
place away from bright light scp-500 is
only allowed to be accessed by personnel
with level 4 security clearance to
prevent misapplication
description scp-500 is a small plastic
can which at the time of writing
contains 47 red pills one pill when
taken orally effectively cures the
subject of all diseases within two hours
exact time depending on the severity and
amount of the subjects conditions
despite extensive trials all attempts at
synthesizing more of what is thought to
be the active ingredient of the pills
has been unsuccessful note from dr.
Klein SCP personnel below level three
are now banned from handling scp-500
this is not to be used to cure a
hangover get AIDS then ask permission
[Music]
request 517 74k doctor 500 double zero
double 2f has requested one scp-500 bill
for testing with SCP 38 request has been
approved request 500 1862 b dr gears has
requested one scp-500 pill for testing
in scp-914 request has been approved
request 523 54 f doctor has requested
one scp-500 pill for testing with SCP
253 request denied
request 550 667 e dr. gibbons has
requested two pills of scp-504 his
personal med kit request denied
addendum 500 - one two pills have been
authorized for use with SCP eight of
conducting a series of tests on Class D
subjects infected with SC p 8p @ even in
the most advanced stages of the disease
one whole pill will accomplish full
recovery number of pills is 57 at the
time of writing doctor 500 double zero
21 D addendum 500 - 2 one pill has been
authorized for use with scp-409 scp-500
was tested on subject 409 d 5 who was
exposed to the effects of scp-409
complete recovery accomplished see
addendum 409 - wha number of pills is 56
at the time of writing doctor 500 double
0 to 1 d
addendum 500 - for request 500 1774 k
approved five bills have been used in an
experimentation with SCP 38 it has been
determined that SCP 38 is capable of
duplicating scp-500 however the success
of the duplicated pills is limited the
duplicated pills are only effective in
curing the subject 30 percent of the
time with chance of successful healing
dropping as time since cloned increases
in 60% of the cases where the infection
is permanent symptoms of infection
remain though further infestation is
neutralized repeated dosing whether CP
38 cloned pills is recommended for all
personnel suffering from incurable
conditions as supply of scp-500 remains
extremely limited
all five used samples of scp-500 were
returned number of pills is 56 at the
time of writing addendum 500 - 5
experiments with SCP 38 one pill was
stolen by personnel thief 2 reportedly
cure a hangover stricter controls for
samples of scp-500 given to other
projects is suggested personnel D has
been terminated number of pills is 55 at
the time of writing
addendum 500 - 6 1 pill has been used
with SCP 231 - for number of pills is 54
at the time of writing addendum 500 - 7
1 pill has been used for experiment for
47 a number of pills is 53 at the time
of writing addendum 508 one pill has
been used with SCP 208 number of pills
is 52 at the time of writing addendum
500 - 9 request 518 60 to be approved
one pill of scp-500 is placed within
scp-914 with the setting at fine
resulting object classified as scp-427
number of pills is 51 at the time of
writing addendum 500 - 10-5 pills have
been taken for the Olympia project
although only two were used the
remaining three will be returned shortly
upon return number of pills will be 49
[Music]
addendum 500 - 11 - pills have been used
for experiment - one set
number of pills is 47 at the time of
writing addendum 500 - 12 request to
have scp-500 investigated for mental
compulsion leading to obsessive fixation
denied for triviality
[Music]
[Music]
you